- [Instructor] The base of a
solid is the region enclosed
by the graphs of y is
equal to negative x squared
plus six x minus one
and y is equal to four.
Cross sections of the solid
perpendicular to the x-axis
are rectangles whose height is x.
Express the volume of the
solid with a definite integral.
So pause this video, and see
if you can have a go at that.
All right, now what's
interesting about this
is they've just given us the
equations for the graphs,
but we haven't visualized them yet.
And we need to visualize
them, or at least I like
to visualize them so I can
think about this region
that they're talking about.
So maybe a first thing
to do is think about,
well, where do these two lines intersect?
So when do we have the same y-value?
Or another way to think about it is
when does this thing equal four?
So if we set them equal to each other,
we have negative x squared
plus six x minus one is equal to four.
This will give us the x-values
where these two lines intersect.
And so we will get, if
we want to solve for x,
we can subtract four from both sides.
Negative x squared plus six x
minus five is equal to zero.
We can multiply both
sides by negative one.
We will get x squared minus six x
plus five is equal to zero.
And then this is pretty
straightforward to factor.
One times five is five,
or actually I say negative one
times negative five is five.
And negative one plus
negative five is negative six.
So it's going to be x minus one
times x minus five is equal to zero.
And so these intersect
when x is equal to one
or x is equal to five.
Since we have a negative out front
of the second-degree term right over here,
we know it's going to be a
downward-opening parabola.
And we know that we
intersect y equals four
when x is equal to one and x equals five.
And so the vertex must
be right in between them,
so the vertex is going
to be at x equals three.
So let's actually visualize
this a little bit.
So it's going to look something like this.
I'll draw it with some perspective
'cause we're gonna have
to think about a three-dimensional shape.
So that's our y-axis.
This is
our
x-axis.
And let me draw some y-values.
So one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven, eight.
This is probably sufficient.
Now we have y is equal to four,
which is going to look
something like this.
So that is
y is equal to four.
And then we have y is
equal to negative x squared
plus six x minus one,
which we know intersects
y equals four at x equals
one or x equals five.
So let's see, one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
So x equals one, so we have
that point right over there.
One comma four, and then
we have five comma four.
And then we know the vertex
is when x is equal to three,
so it might look something like this.
We could substitute three back in here.
So let's see, y will
equal to negative nine,
three squared,
plus 18
minus one.
And so what is that going to be?
That's going to be y is
going to be equal to eight.
So we have the point three comma eight.
So this is five, six, seven,
eight, yep, right about there.
And so we are dealing with a situation,
we're dealing with a situation that looks
something like this.
This is the region in question.
So that's going to be
the base of our solid.
And they say cross sections of the solid
perpendicular to the x-axis,
so let me draw one of
those cross sections.
So this is a cross section
perpendicular to the x-axis,
are rectangles, whose height is x,
so this is going to have
height x right over here,
height x.
Now what is this, the
width, I guess we could say,
of this rectangle?
Well, it's going to be the difference
between these two functions.
It's going to be these,
this upper function minus
this lower function.
So it's going to be, that
right over there is going
to be negative x squared
plus six x minus one
and then minus four,
minus the lower function.
So that could be simplified
as negative x squared
plus six x minus five.
And so if we wanna figure out the volume
of this little section right over here,
we'd multiply x times this,
and then we would multiply that
times an infinitesimal small,
infinitesimally small depth, dx.
And then we can just
integrate from x equals one
to x equals five.
So let's do that.
The volume of just this
little slice over here
is going to be the base,
which is negative x squared
plus six x minus five,
times the height, times x,
times the depth, times dx.
And then what we wanna do is
we wanna sum up all of these.
So you could imagine right
over here, you would have,
or like right over here,
you would have a cross
section that looks like this.
X is now much larger.
The height is x, so now it
looks something like this.
So I'm just drawing two cross sections,
just so you get the idea.
So these are the,
this is any one cross
section for a given x,
but now we want to integrate.
Our x is going from x
equals one to x equals five,
x equals one to x equals five.
And there you have it, we
have expressed the volume
of that solid as a definite integral.
And it's worth noting that this is,
that this definite integral,
if you distribute this x,
if you multiply it by all of these terms,
it's very solvable.
You don't need a,
or it's very solvable
without a calculator.
You're just going to get
a polynomial over here
that you have to take
the antiderivative of
in order to evaluate
the definite integral.